en este vídeo vamos a tratar de calcular
un límite de esta función para valores
de x que se van haciendo cada vez más y
más y más grandes es decir queremos
calcular el límite de una función cuando
x tiende a infinito así que esta función
es la raíz cuadrada de 100 más x menos
la raíz cuadrada de x y te invito a que
hagas una pausa y que trates de
descubrir cuál es este límite aunque sea
intuitivamente
así que suponiendo que ya hiciste esta
pausa lo que podemos notar de este
primer sumando es que si la equis es muy
pero muy pero muy grande no sé quizás
trillones mil trillones cuatrillones qué
sé yo este cien es fijo y cada vez
importa muy poco es decir este cien
contribuye muy poquito esta suma cuando
la x es cada vez más grande así que
podríamos pensar y de hecho vamos a ir
escribiendo estas ideas que para valores
valores x digamos realmente grandes
realmente grandes
grandes y voy a subrayar el realmente
nosotros podemos pensar que raíz de 100
más x esta raíz pues se parecerá a la
raíz de x verdad porque el 100 cada vez
contribuye muy poquito en relación de
qué tan grande se va haciendo nuestra x
así que podríamos pensar que cómo se va
apareciendo el límite cuando x tiene
infinito de esto pues va a ser cero
porque se van a aparecer cada vez más
muy bien entonces bueno esto por
supuesto no es una demostración de
nuestro de nuestra intuición esto es
algo que creemos creemos que es cero
pero hay que dar un argumento algebraico
o un argumento matemático concreto y
correcto así que vamos a manipular
algebraica mente esta expresión tenemos
la raíz la raíz cuadrada de gm
grueso la raíz cuadrada de 100 más x
raíz cuadrada de 100 más x
le restamos la raíz cuadrada de x así
que para modificar esto lo que
necesitamos es encontrar alguna forma de
cambiar esta expresión pero sin cambiar
su valor por ejemplo multiplicando por 1
si nosotros multiplicamos esto por 1
pues queda igual sin embargo hay que
elegir un uno adecuado es decir una
forma de escribir uno de forma correcta
y una forma de escribir uno es por
ejemplo si si multiplicamos esto por su
conjugado por ejemplo si multiplicamos
por raíz de 100 más x ahí lo tienen
más la raíz de equis y hay que dividir
entre lo mismo para que nos dé 1 que es
la raíz de 100 más x más la raíz de x
ahora porque elegimos esto bueno pues
esencialmente es porque las raíces
cuadradas nos nos causan conflictos no
nos gustan
así que si multiplicamos por el
conjugado podemos hacer uso de que esto
nos va a dar una diferencia de cuadrados
y eso eliminaría nuestras raíces
cuadradas muy bien entonces vamos a ver
esto que es lo que nos quedaría bueno
vamos a dejar este denominador que es la
raíz de 100 más x
es la raíz cuadrada de equis y luego
quedaría arriba y vamos a dejarlo con
rojo nos quedaría la raíz cuadrada de
100 más x menos la raíz cuadrada de x
que multiplica que multiplica al otro
factor que es la raíz cuadrada de 100
más x
perdón aquí sería más la raíz cuadrada
de x muy bien entonces qué es lo que nos
va a dar esto si nos damos cuenta este
es un producto de la forma a menos ve
por a más ve entonces lo que nos va a
quedar es una diferencia de cuadrados
donde vamos a elevar este al cuadrado
que es igual a éste y luego vamos a
restarle este al cuadrado
este al cuadrado muy bien entonces que
es lo que nos queda
tendremos 100 más x
100 más x raíz cuadrada al cuadrado es
100 más x verdad menos raíz de x al
cuadrado es x muy bien y todo esto lo
dividimos entre lo que ya tenemos en el
denominador que es raíz de 100 raíz de
100 más x
la raíz de x muy bien y esto que será
igual bueno estos estas x se cancelan
verdad y simplemente nos queda lo
siguiente nos queda 100 entre esta raíz
de 100 más x más la raíz de x por lo
tanto este límite original que queríamos
calcular lo podemos reescribir de la
siguiente forma déjenme quitar este
igual que no iba a y ahí está
entonces el límite original va a ser el
límite cuando x tiende a infinito de
quien de 100
de 100 entre la raíz de 100 x
más la raíz de x ahora la ventaja que
tenemos es que el numerador ya es fijo
este ya es fijo y no cambia en cambio
acá abajo acá abajo estamos aumentando
el valor de x cada vez más esta función
de aquí es no acotada se va calculando
la raíz de 100 más trillones más la raíz
de trillones entonces esto de aquí se va
haciendo cada vez más y más y más grande
pero está en un denominador por lo tanto
este número 100 se va dividiendo entre
partes cada vez más y más y más grandes
así que esto se aproxima exactamente a
cero muy bien lo cual fue muy
consistente con nuestra intuición
original pero esto ya es una
demostración